[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the after show today
we're gonna break down bullet train
diving deep on the details and answering
some of the burning questions left by
the film now i have to warn everyone we
are definitely going to be getting into
the plot details for this one so this is
going to be a spoiler-filled recap if
you haven't seen the film i suggest you
turn it off now save it wherever you can
and come back you've been warned
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car
god he's a small inside voice in his son
there's a gun jumping into it today i'm
joined with one of my favorite folks to
talk movies with this is koi jandru he's
a host pundit and comic book historian
koi sir this is not technically within
what i normally talk to you about
there's not as many capes in this one
there's a few actually though there are
capes uh but this is a great one glad to
have you back yeah this is very much a
comic vein movie so i'm glad to be here
because i i love movies and i rarely get
to venture out of the capes and cowl so
it's nice to be here yeah exactly and i
will say to your point we're not
venturing too far from it but let's go
ahead and jump right into where the film
stands as far as reception currently
right now it is 54 rated on the tomato
meter by critics and it has an audience
score of 78 so rotten by critics
pretty fresh uh by the audience
standpoint but not as high as you
typically see with audience scores the
critics consensus is bullet trains
colorful casts and high-speed action are
almost enough to keep things going after
the story runs out of track all right
koi what do you think who are you
aligned with on this one critics or the
audience so where they say rotten
tomatoes is wrong i would definitely be
arguing for
the audience and i think it's just a
slight world view shift in that sentence
even it's it's just enough to keep me
going it wasn't a home run but it
definitely ran some bases i went into
this wanting much like rayman an action
comedy thriller like i enjoyed in the
90s i wanted a movie that i would wander
into blockbusters see a shiny cover walk
out throw it in and go haha i didn't
want a lot more than that and i
definitely got that i really enjoyed
that it didn't tie to other things but
it also gave me the sense of world
building i enjoyed that it was a giant
cast of characters that felt like some
messed up ocean's eleven and i really
liked that i didn't have to
have a lot going on
intellectually to enjoy some of those
moments but i also didn't feel dumber
for enjoying it sometimes movies are
like actively insulting and i'm still
like this was great but oh no i'm lesser
for enjoying it i didn't feel any of
those things but i definitely felt like
it captured the spirit of that 90s
action thriller i wanted
yeah maybe because like
there was a time
and in fact i would say there's even
that time is still now that i lived for
every like caper movie that either
matthew vaughn or guy ritchie or the
combination of the two of those together
i felt they were like lawrence bender
and quentin tarantino they were just
like going to be a producing directing
partner that just kept ringing this bell
uh for decades to come and then
eventually vaughn became a director on
his own and i also thought he was gonna
ring those bells and so like
this movie is meant for me in the sense
of i love this genre of um filmmaking i
love the sort of tongue-in-cheek and
like i get it 30 million at the domestic
62 million worldwide i think audiences
for the most part are about it but
i don't know man it's it this is one of
those ones where i'm like
if you're gonna serve me it's sort of
like a cover song if you're gonna cover
a very popular song like jolene
something that dolly parton did and many
people have like tried to like
do a different way if you're gonna do it
you better bring the fire i agree with
that and that's a great yeah that's a
great way to look at it too is it is a
guy richie cover and and david leach is
a different generally to me type of
director than guy richie i think what
guy richie manages to do especially like
i really love the gentleman i think the
gentleman doesn't get enough love i put
the gentleman up there like with with
snatch even like it's it's in my it's in
my like number one spot it kind of
dances but what i think that movie did
really well was there was an
undercurrent of really high brow thought
that is delivered in a fun low-brow way
and i feel like this one tries to get
some of those metaphors and allegories
and they don't really feel like anything
they feel like someone read something
whispered it to someone else and then by
the end of a long game of telephone
they're on screen and i don't know whose
fault that would be but my thing was
with david leach he's such a good
director visually and he's such a good
stunt director i didn't mind that those
things didn't land and i think if
someone else tried to guy richie it
would bother me more it's like i was i
wanted uh you know a peanut butter and
jelly and when i got a peanut butter and
jam it was okay slightly different
texture still had a good time so it
still gave me that salty sweet i wanted
it's so interesting you say that too
because david leach was part of the john
wick pair that actually uh made that
film it was weird the way that they
actually had to
label them they were directing sort of
pair and they worked with keanu as a
pair and then they sort of split off
between david leach doing like the
deadpool universe and a lot i would say
bigger action things and
chad i think more sticking into that
grittier lower budget indie action film
and i think as we sort of break down the
film and really
discuss why i liked and didn't is
because of those two particular
different styles like i think that for
what david leach had to play with which
included in addition to a pretty
all-star class all-star cast of brad and
sandra aaron taylor johnson brian tyree
henry who also doesn't just choose
random crazy things to do he's a pretty
i think selective actor as well as far
as the roles that he chooses all of them
come together and the best we can get is
to me personally i think rock and roller
did it better i can think of like
through one of these movies that did it
better 10 years ago and that's the
problem i have with it i get that it's
fun i'm not saying that it's not but you
still have brad pitt sandra bullock and
then also
like the other thing i look at is like
if you command a ryan reynolds and
channing tatum cameo for your movie can
you at least give them more to do
than what we had them do in this which
is basically the gag of like oh they
show up and give little to nothing look
at channing tatum's uh cameo in this is
the end and compare it to this what's
interesting to me is it it feels like
they did a lost city like sister film
and that one did that thing better like
i think lost city did the cameo with
purpose better than this when they did
cameo without purpose but to my 90s
thing this did feel more like the 90s
when that was enough like on it like to
be this was a movie star filled cast and
we don't really have movie stars
anymore as a box office draw we have you
know uh ip we've got uh certain elements
of story we've got things that our box
office draws maybe by director or genre
but rarely do you go like oh sandra
bullock and brad pitt are doing a movie
and have that pull in so i think that
was part of honestly the the uh
hollywood video blockbuster uh family
video store element where it looked like
i turned over the back cover and i went
ah and all these people were in it and
that was what they made on purpose but i
i think the thing that you
didn't like was kind of the thing i did
like in that i don't feel like we get
enough guy richie and matt vaughn so and
it maybe it's me just like clamoring but
i find that like the king's man didn't
feel like matthew vaughn to me it felt
like someone doing matthew vaughn and i
find uh aladdin didn't work for me as a
guy richie film it was like you just
took guy ricky away from me for two
years so i think the more i want those
two to be in their element the more i'm
like whatever is close to that i'll
accept so i really liked this giving me
the taste of it even if it was from
another angle so i i can guarantee like
i give this around a b b minus i think
if guy richie and matt vaughn were still
making those things they did it would be
in the c range but i'm just so hungry
for that type of genre that i'm willing
to accept it even if it's a little uh
watered down yeah i i will agree with
you on the water down what i think is
interesting is the guy richie's and the
matthew vaughn's people that brought you
layer cake and snatch say what you will
too about either of those films there
was a story through line that was
anchored by these incredible cast of
characters like yes i get it it's funny
to make the fuji bottle be a through
line throughout the story and the whole
tangerine oranges all of those things
were cute and clever but there's nothing
compared to the like literal through
line of the dog in snatch or like
looking at you know the careful way they
weave that we don't know who the lead
character is and something like layer
cake like these what i would say much
more careful aspects of story are what i
found lacking in this one it's just like
they knew the movie was all style no
substance and they didn't care anything
about making that any better uh because
they had brad pitt
and all of the other folks that come
along with it which i will say of
everything that i didn't dig with there
are certain people in this movie even if
i didn't even dig what they were doing
in this movie compared to other work i
was like y'all are having fun doing it
and i enjoyed watching you do it and i
would say brad pitt
is not at the top of my list for that
but he is definitely like he just seems
like he is just living in his newly
divorced dad juices like i don't know if
luke
i don't know what he's on but he's
having fun one of the first things i
said in my review was like love it or
hate it everyone had a great time making
it like it seems to be like like brad
pitt at the premiere like like just
floating on air wearing like that linen
green suit and like twirling around that
felt like the dynamic on set like when
you watch this movie it's like brian
tyree henry and aaron taylor johnson got
to bro out and become best friends brad
pitt got to do a lot of brad pitt isms
but didn't get to like didn't have to do
the insane overbearing dramatic work in
between the brad pitt stuff like you
know you look at brad pitt's career he's
got like 80s heartthrob phase he's got
90s indy darling leading up to the fight
club 7 era then you've got like brad
pitt movie star where he's like
constantly eating and charming and
schmoozing but in each of those movies
up until that point you still have that
dramatic scene to be like this is why we
paid him to me this movie was what if we
don't make brad pitt suffer through the
emotional like through line and we let
him instead do a few stunts with his old
stunt double and just have a good time
chewing on stuff like whether it's
scenery or food and that to me was like
enough to warrant i'm really happy for
everyone involved i don't mind the fact
that this plot point is erroneous with
the snake or the fact that this like
character doesn't have a real tie-in
they just made up michael shannon's
daughter like those things were like
okay why not like here we are that is
actually the one that i question this is
how like michael shannon agreed to do
this he is the one i cannot get through
because you're right there's like a lost
city of z vibe to it there's the like
anything connected to david leach like
connection through it there's the like
hey i'm brad pitt so obviously you
probably want to work with me connection
to it what did michael shannon need out
of this
i'm like legitimately baffled the whole
movie is setting up to reveal and like
i'd forgotten he was in it and i
remember being excited for it and they
did a great job by by making me forget
so the whole time like if they've
already had ryan reynolds cameo they've
already had this great i liked the
channing tatum cameo i thought like
it wasn't bad i'm just saying for that
it could have been more i think one more
bit of it would have would have locked
it in i think it was like one like laugh
too little like i wanted one more taste
and then it would have been great
because i love the character and i love
the evolution of even his two little
beats they were really funny to me but
the michael shannon was really funny
because i was waiting i was waiting i
was waiting he took his mask off and i
was more confused that i as a film
pundit was unaware and then i was like
did i know this i think i know this is
that michael shannon like i doubted it
was him because of how incredulous i was
that he was in front screen in front of
me
i mean i wasn't incredulous about it but
i will say
it was definitely one of those things
where i'm like something about this is
just him doing whatever he feels like
maybe he's friends with leach maybe he
just wanted to work with brad pitt i
don't know
but honestly if i'm being really honest
it might be the fact honestly i think i
figured it out now i figured it out plan
b
which is brad pitt's production company
this is what's so sad about this movie
the biggest thing we want to talk about
is how people manage to sign up to do it
and that right there says enough about
the film the business of blizzard
yeah plan b is a production company i'd
be willing to bet in addition to
starring in movies with like plan b or
like alongside i'm sure i'm gonna find
the through line through brad pitt and i
just didn't clock it off the top of my
head like there's somebody on twitter
that's gonna see this and be like they
started a movie together or he produced
this movie for him so actually i take
that back but still
i don't care how many movies you
produced um
let's keep it real like
i'm just impressed that they were able
to pull like this together when they did
this was in the pandemic this was you
know dealing with all those insane
safety precautions and it didn't there
were a couple moments where i was like
oh this is an isolated set like this
train only has two people in the car
because that's a safer thing for the
actors to film but overall i really
enjoyed the fact that this felt like a
giant ensemble not like something you
had to make in isolation but then as a
film you know consumer to this mass
level you can start to then piece
together oh this is why this is why this
is why but i think the thing i was most
impressed by was you've got this much of
a stacked cast and the stunts felt
largely practical and i think that
elevates it from that c to a b minus for
me as well because i miss practical
stunts and david leach is a huge
proponent of that he's got 87 north here
in la where it's like a stunt school
he's got a lot of stunt people that are
always riding with him and whether that
worked tonally or not when they do
flashback scenes to like feudal japan or
samurai warriors or any of those things
me knowing those are real warriors with
swords is always going to make me go
like oh i'm invested whether it works or
not i'm at least into that level because
i know it's going to be a real person
doing a real stunt and that way even
when brad pitt's flying through a bullet
train like defying gravity and dodging
stuff
having that be one of the first obvious
cgi scenes there's obviously cgi
integrated without this film but that
was one of the first visuals that like
felt like it couldn't be real i was like
oh how nice that we're this deep in a
two hour and twenty minute film and this
is the first time my brain's like cg it
was it was refreshing
yeah i will say this it's refreshing i'm
not going to pretend that it isn't um
with the practicality of it the realism
of it but
again look let's see where this thing is
borrowing this thing is borrowing
directly from some things like it's
borrowing from pretty much every train
action movie ever but of course we're
gonna think about uh train to busan but
it's also really borrowing heavily in
just this idea of the cast of
shady characters coming together to do
the one little mission so it is very you
know uh the dirty dozen type you know
we're on a mission together even though
we are the worst person very suicide
squad type endeavor which is great if
you know this is david leach saying to
himself you know james gunn dave air had
their shot at suicide squad let me give
you mine like this is a great calling
card for that however
i will just go back to it even brian
tyree henry who was one of my favorite
performances throughout this and it was
so great i still don't feel like this is
something where i'm saying to myself
yeah that's what i needed to see from
him on the flavor because what did he
actually do besides come through with a
series of like what i like to consider
funny tic toc skips
action thing now granted they're like
great they're like so great but they're
really like these like very elaborate
very splashy action scenes that have no
connective tissue or emotional resonance
the most emotional resonant moment from
this literally came courtesy of a joke
at the end with oranges and there is a
girl on a train trying to murder her
father like this is a lot you know what
i'm saying i definitely think the style
of her substance when it comes to
again the brad pitt of it all brad pitt
didn't have to do that emotional through
line neither did brian tyree henry near
darren taylor johnson and these are
great actors everyone in this is a
powerhouse everyone in this would be
headlining any other movie but since the
ensemble's so big like literally pull
one of these people out put them on a
poster they're the poster that said i
can't describe anyone's emotional
journey and yet i walked out smiling so
i know the style was 110 to make up for
the 30 emotional
resonance and i don't know if as uh you
know me at a certain age i'm okay with
that because when these movies were
coming out of the 90s i was seven like i
don't know if it's like a muscle memory
to nostalgia or if it's just i consider
the genre a thinner genre but we keep
referencing guy richie and i do think
that he does this genre but with the
emotional resonance he doesn't get
credit for and i think that's what
separates this film from the things it's
pulling from yes no i
don't disagree with you on that in
any asp in any way shape or form on on
that part of it but i would still just
push back on the fact that like
it is guy richie esque but guy richie
got accused of being a copy of quentin
tarantino and in all honesty putting
bullet train at the end of them it's
maybe like a multiplicity type situation
where the copy of the copy is not
yeah but i would just say that's only if
you're robbing the style
because when you look at the like
plotting character development and i
would say richness of quentin
tarantino's movies
yeah you could maybe say that
guy richie is making that copy and so it
is weaker but the distance from point a
to point b is like
much further when you're talking about
the plot character side on guy richie
and so really i don't even put him as a
comparison of quentin tarantino
literally it is a copy of guy richie and
it is a copy of guy ritchie 15 years
later with people for the most part who
could have starred in a guy ritchie
movie and in fact in the case of aaron
taylor johnson by extension he kind of
did and so i'm like if you're literally
making a movie that is 15 two years late
starring people that could have starred
in this the first time around and in a
lot of cases obviously did as well with
with brad pitt at least do it better
like and that i think they they did
better in some of the stunts like i
would put the stunts in this up against
some of the stunts in the guy ritchie
movies and i put the stunts the actual
practical stunts in this up against
steven tarantino as far as hand-to-hand
combat as far as like
yeah the visual framing and elements
that are very david leech the leech of
this is superior to the the leech of
other things but that didn't get the
time to shine enough for this being a
david leech film like i i do think there
could have been a bit more hand to hand
and i know there was probably like four
or five set pieces but in a david leech
film that's 220 i could have used some
more of the things that he does better
instead of him doing the things that
other people do so i definitely won't
argue that this is like plato's the cave
right like every time you copy the image
of something it dilutes like this is
definitely the allegory of the cave come
to fruition it's like the fifth sequel
of something which is why i find it to
be
comedic to the point of almost hubris
the fact that this thing sets up a
sequel like legitimacy
yeah this movie is already so late it is
not even pregnant it is pregnant giving
birth and sent the kid to college like
that is how late this movie is in
comparison to like where it would have
fit in the zeitgeist right
and it is already in my opinion a bit
more of a bigger budget watered-down
version i albeit with much more
heightened action of something we've
already seen
and then they're like and we're going to
give you more of it in a sequelized
serialized version like i know they made
a smoking ace's sequel
this is going to be smokiness too i
cannot see it being any other way
maybe you could see do you actually
actually i'll put it this way do you
think that if they make this a sequel
because it seems that they clearly want
to
if they do do you have any faith that
this could be a situation where the
sequel surpasses the original are you
assuming that it's this this is uh i
there's a reason in the era where this
type of film was popular that sequels
didn't do well and i feel like this is
exactly it like we didn't get to really
investing in sequels like there was the
occasional obviously your t2 your aliens
all the ones that people bring up but
there's a reason those stand out as they
were exceptions to the rule if you look
at when blockbuster was thriving sequels
were not doing well thirds were not
doing well i think we're working on
sequels again now i think we're better
at sequels now because we're looking at
things as franchises they know that if
the second one flops there is no third
or fifth or seventh so i do think that
the era this comes from is the age of
let's get it made if it makes money
we'll make another one it's not really
about arcs because these characters in
the one film don't have arcs why would i
sequel allow for arcs this movie was
about being really really shiny and i
liked how shiny it was that being said i
will be watching the sequel so i'm part
of the problem i'm very excited for
being trained too i am part of the
problem i know what i am and i'm very
i'm there thursday midnight i'm all
about it because i want more guy ritchie
i want more shiny and if they're not
going to do it i need someone else to do
it and if that's david leech i'm there
you know what is really funny i read
that quote recently where tarantino was
talking about how he loved watching top
gun because it gave him a tony scott
movie which it did like this yeah 100
just absolutely in the vein of
everything that that tony scott did and
could create but what i think is even
more interesting about it
is this is kind of like that and so i'm
actually gonna say this i don't know who
gets involved in the sequel
uh to bullet train but
if it has any chance of being good they
can only make it good if they creed to
this thing meaning
david leach is literally like of the
same age of guy richie the only way to
actually do something different and
really like expand the genre is to give
it to somebody who has a perspective on
it that has never ever ever been seen
and give them that that's what they did
with creed and rocky so it was like
we're gonna give you a rocky movie but
we're gonna give you from a perspective
that you're so not even going to
recognize that you're not even going to
clock it's still just a rocky movie
because it's going to feel so different
you know i'd love to get a kid that's
like a kid like a young straight out of
film school director that's inspired by
guy ritchie i see what you're saying i
totally agree because because like what
ryan coogler was able to do from the
perspective of creed was give us what
philly is today
versus what philly was ben so i'd love
to see what someone coming up in like
soho like someone coming up from like
rough neighborhoods in england which is
what what guy ritchie was doing and
matthew vaughn was doing that and then
someone that's going to find jason
statham selling watches exactly i need
someone that's going to find their lock
stock era exactly and i think they've
done that but all the ones that they do
are usually like rooted in pain i want
to see the funny version of that and in
fact there's a film that played at
sundance uh called emergency which is
similar to that but they're not like a
cast of like like better luck tomorrow
is an example of this and that's exactly
what i think we could have happen with
bullet train and make it
interesting for a sequel but i think if
they're just like let's just get more
a-listers and i'm not even saying that
you can't do a-listers but i'm just
saying if they just do it with the same
what i would say
cast of folks with leech back again and
another script like
what's interesting is i want to see and
this is not to put leech in the same
category as this director they're just
in the same so this don't attack the
internet let me get to the end of the
point is what i'm doing don't start
typing it i love leech as the same
element that i love about
bey and snyder
i think michael bay i think zack snyder
and i think david leach are some of the
best second unit directors for a style
but i think leech is the best of that
style i think leech does what i want the
best second unit directors to do which
is really really really focused on
certain elements of the story i would
love to see leech team up with someone
again that it has more of the the heart
of of the emotional sensibility of the
character arc tying into his best of
stunt world element because i i honestly
would put leach up against anyone for
what leach does best so i would honestly
maybe love to see the ryan coogler
element as teamed up with david leach so
i can keep the things i loved about this
film and i can keep the elements that i
think do work for what david leech does
but extrapolate that out and honestly
maybe maybe grow david leitch's arcs and
through lines of character because i
think what he did with deadpool was
really interesting because he had the
sequel have to be bigger and bigger and
bigger and he had some really
interesting elements that really worked
emotionally but only in like sections of
the film it didn't feel like the first
second or third act of the film affected
the other acts and that and that i feel
like this film had as well like by the
time we got to the stuff with the
michael shannon i didn't the michael's
training by the time i got to michael
shannon i wasn't as invested in jamie
king's character by the time we got to
uh brad pitt really self-actualizing
about being a zen master woo-woo i'd
already left behind all of his stuff in
the first act so i think if you have
someone steering what the
consistent pulse is while you're letting
him
drive the pulse with action i think you
could have the best of both but i would
want someone on the sequel that is going
to keep david leach in that perspective
shift and i don't know if he's in a
headspace or if that's what he wants i i
just think that's the way to elevate a
sequel and see honestly i don't think
that's what this appeals to him in the
first place i think it is and i think he
is like guy ritchie in this and guy
ritchie was especially like this
actually tarantino was like this
actually scorsese is like this and so is
spielberg and a lot of these directors
that reach this point when you get to a
certain point it's just about kicking it
with and making stuff with people that
you like like oh yeah he's definitely
adam sandler in here yeah like adam
sandler that's exactly exactly the way
to put it it is really just this idea of
hey
this are the people i like to kick it
with we're going to go make a movie in
hawaii we're going to go make a movie in
budapest and we're all going to have a
good time you're not going to get your
rate but we're going to have fun we're
going to put the right people under
producers so that way hopefully if we
make enough in the box office you guys
get it on the other side let's go and
that's what they do and honestly i'm
kind of like
i get it like this is i always bring up
food on rotten tomatoes i don't know if
it's called tomatoes but food always
comes to mind but this to me feels like
someone ate a really really good
sandwich once in say italy and then they
came back to the states and they don't
have the same ingredients but they want
to recreate that sandwich and that
sandwich is very good because they're
also a great sandwich artist and you're
having a good time but you're aware of
the original sandwich while you're
eating it what i would love is if david
leach embraced what made his sandwiches
better and then maybe someone brought in
some of their own toppings but i really
want a uniquely david leach sandwich
again and i feel like as long as
directors like guy ritchie are doing
blockbusters like aladdin or matthew
vaughn is doing you know world war one
slash kingsman movies we keep diluting
these sandwiches and i would really like
to go when i choose this sandwich to be
at that place not this weird hodgepodge
and i think that's what's actually
affecting me about these franchise films
is when you go watch doctor strange and
it's a sam raimi film that appeases the
sam raimi people so much more than a
half mcu half sam rainey film but it
doesn't fit in the mcu so what's tricky
is that mcu is the chain restaurant that
doesn't really allow for how spicy this
sandwich is but at the same time that's
what people are going for so i think we
need to separate our franchises from our
archer films and if that if that was a
what if instead of part of the mcu i
would have loved an entire letter grade
more so again i'm part of the problem
but we need to decide what these things
are are they part of a giant series are
we getting our own anthologies this
thing could have been its own thing
without worrying about setting up a
sequel but i i feel like it was just
trying to be one too many things one too
many plot points one too many through
lines didn't land for me
yeah and hey look they could get cleaned
up in a sequel it could be a situation
where we're just gonna get more of the
same i think it really to your point
depends on who is in the driver's seat
one thing i will say
is for all of the bad bunny fans out
there i apologize
ah
this was such a cardi b and hustler
situation and it made me so so mad for
those people because now more than
anything like i believe we are back in
the like
remember like one of my friends just
tweeted that they're watching that thing
you do but the thing i remember about
that movie is they like go and have like
a day where they film like on a movie
set and it's just because they have a
hit record that they get to come and do
that that is what it's like seeing bad
bunny in a movie like this like he does
a good job he obviously learned some
stunts for this yeah like gets really
physically into it so i'm not trying to
say he just showed up for a check but
like
he should be in the movie longer than
that you know he's actually one of the
people that i i i highlight that moment
as when leech was full each like that's
actually one of those moments i pull out
as this is what i wanted more of i
wanted david leach choreographing a
stunt scene in a confined space with two
actors that are like very well versed
apparently like i don't know bad buddy
but two actors that are very well versed
physically because you know brad pitt's
been doing stunts longer than i've been
alive so like he knows how to you know
one tag in his stunt double but two he
knows how to move in the frame and make
sure it feels fluid so that to me is is
the benefit of hiring someone that went
from being a stunt guy to a stunt
coordinator now a stunt director i need
more of that than i need
where we landed in the third act where
it became a different kind of movie so i
think the bad bunny sequence if this was
a movie of like 20 of the 10 of those
segments that build tour crescendo that
would have been more what i was looking
for out of the film so as much as it
wasn't a long enough scene it's one of
the examples of what worked best for me
um it's so crazy too that it's kind of
taken us this long to even start talking
about bad bunny we haven't even talked
about so many of the cast of folks that
are a part of this including zazzy beats
who also had a very
like
i would say st uh scene scene-stealing
moment a scene stealing scene and so
yeah do you um talk about that moment
for folks that you know like got to see
it but exactly why it's so incredible to
see this star from atlanta and also
deadpool so it's not like this is her
first time in it but really pushing the
envelope on what she can do physically
this is definitely lost city meets
atlanta and i'm not mad at it if it had
a donald glover cameo would have been
perfect even if it was just waiting
outside the train you get off the train
there's there's childish and then you
get back but but i think honestly that's
a great example of another scene that
showcases what i love about this film
what kept this out of the sea range into
the b range for me is david leach as
much as we keep mentioning guy ritchie
david leach has this incredible style
this incredible eye this incredible
panache for using actors and stunt
people organically he hires people that
have this great physicality he makes
sure all the stunt people are
beautifully matched with their person
and it's something that i don't find
another a lot of other directors do as
well because a lot of times you watch
these stunt heavy movies there's the
moment you're like that wasn't blankety
blank whoever it was whether it's
because of the stunt person moving
differently seeing their face god forbid
or because of the actor not being able
to set up the stunt person and to me
there are two categories that need to be
in the oscars
10 years ago and that's stunt people and
casting directors and this ties into
both of those things casting directors
are the reason these movies can exist to
the level that we love them whether you
care about movie stars or not when you
talk about a movie one of the first five
things you bring up even if you love
directors you love cinematographers
you've got to mention the actors and if
the movie doesn't flow
the casting directors are usually a part
of that whether director wants them or
not the casting director shapes the
overall it's it's a painting you need
those colors established so the casting
directors are so vital but then right
there with them most movies we see in
theaters are because of the spectacle
most movies we see in theaters need to
be something that can't be done as well
on tv what you can do really well on tv
is tell incredible serialized content
that deals with long emotional journeys
and invest you long form into those
characters we didn't get a lot of that
here but it's not a tv show it's a movie
that needed stunts that needed intensity
and this is a great example of why those
two things need to be more highlighted
in the industry we need the stunt oscar
because none of these movies that make a
billion dollars would exist without
stunned people none of these movies that
get sequels would really exist without
stun people and what david leach is able
to do is he's able to make you invest so
much in the characters
in five minutes that when a punch is
thrown you're invested in both parties
you're invested in the thrower and the
receiver of that punch you care about
that punch landing twice because you
don't wanna you don't wanna feel for
either one of them getting hurt i
immediately cared about zazzy beats i
immediately cared about bad bunny so
every time brad pitt was fighting them
there was a part of me because of the
casting because the stun people that was
like oh no don't win brad pitt like no
one won because i cared about everyone
so that's something i think that david
leach does better than anyone right now
is action directing in the form of
physical contact and connection michael
bay can have a spectacle like he can
have his drones and he can have his
zooms and all those things and you can
have uh you know zack snyder with his
grandiose everything is a god david
leach does the opposite he he invests
you in the person that way the big big
stunt feels personal and i think the
zazi beats was was that to a teep
no i don't disagree with you and again
like i feel bad because people are gonna
be like you didn't talk about you know
mossy okay you didn't talk about uh uh
hiroyuki uh there's just so many folks
logan lerman we have percy jackson
popping in here they're barely there
logan lerman you know what i mean like
they're like advertising logan in the
movie and he's like
barely in it
like his character is called the sun it
doesn't even have a name but again to
your point i think that might be why
everyone signs up to do it is because i
think some of these actors enjoy the
idea of getting physical with it and
sometimes it's like hey is this going to
be the right avenue to do it yeah you
have competent stunt professionals but
it's also what the director is setting
up and i feel like if you're going to do
an action movie where maybe you're
pushing yourself to a physical limit and
really going um further with what you're
able to do
you should do it in the hands of someone
like a david leach or chad uh staldesky
from the other side of the john wick
partnership and i think that's why they
want to do it we talk about you know
what you're emotionally invested in and
we talk about what your experience is
with you know creed we talk about ryan
coogler and what he's able to bring to
an already established story i think
honestly what
leech is able to bring is who better to
know what frame is going to look perfect
and what stunt is even physically
possible than someone that's been on the
other side of that camera and then
someone that's been training the last 10
years to go over here and know how to
frame it know how to shoot it and then
experiment he's gonna get to make a lot
more bolder choices because he's already
seven tenths of the way there he's
already lived up into that point can he
push that last thirty percent and i
think that makes him so unique as a
director is he's willing to push his
stunt people to a certain level and
they're willing to go there for them
because he's a stunt coordinator at
heart that's lived it like i don't trust
them like when you meet uh uh a chef the
skinny chef joke like don't trust a
skinny chef don't trust a stunt
coordinator that's never been a stunty
don't trust the director the risk your
life if they've never done it he's one
of the best to ever do it so him behind
the camera is really exciting for me as
someone that has i've done stunts i've
i've lived that side of it and now i
want to see more of that in movies and i
feel like he captures it better than
anyone and yeah i i i want more of of
that in his films and i hope that
studios let him just make
contained brawls
i want the jetly
jackie chan era to come back by way of
him and i think that actors want i think
there's a point in actors career where
they go from like when you're an up and
coming actor you want to make a real
right you want to make like i got this
dramatic scene i got this stunt scene
this is me with this celebrity i think
there's a moment when you become a movie
star they're like what do i want as a
human being for my reel to be like what
do i want when i live my life and look
back i want to work at brad pitt but i
also want to do a stunt throwing zombie
beats around a train like i think those
are two things that that coexist in
leech movies and i honestly the more i
talk about this movie the more i enjoy
it like right now i'm like maybe is it a
bb plus but like there's so much to it
from that perspective that i love i
agree real quick though just to give us
some final thoughts who was your
favorite of the cast of characters and
who was one that you were like i don't
know why you're here
um i'll at least go first with my
favorite i love brian tyree henry
obviously he got gifted some of the best
jokes in the film a lot of the emotional
resonance i just i loved love loved
everything that he did what about you uh
i would have done brian tyree henry too
but for the sake of not having the same
because he's just like he's everywhere i
think he's got
that resume that shows his team and he
have a 10-year plan and this was a
different thing for him like i love that
this is a different element to his his
repertoire and also he's not playing
anywhere near the same type character i
really like that i was watching atlanta
two days before i watched this and i was
like that is not paperboy and it's good
to see an actor in his first 10 years
really feel the different elements of
where he can go with his
characterization but also still feel
like him like he's a chameleon but you
still see some of the same colors in his
work which i always enjoy i like that
he's got like a thing about him uh aaron
taylor johnson i also thought was great
i thought for me the emotional resonance
was between the two of them that was the
one thing i felt uh the brotherhood
between the two of them i genuinely felt
the yeah let me go with him because i
felt the emotional romeo and juliet of
them losing each other and then
realizing and i actually cared so that
delivered for me what the guy richie
emotional resonance did because these
are criminals these aren't good people
these aren't people that you generally
want to spend a lot of time with but i
cared about their journey to the point
where like i forgave a lot of their
being shitty people so that duo as a
team was what i wanted the movie to be
so i think the combination of those two
actors playing and they do seem to
generally have a bond and i feel like
brad pitt's the easy answer so i'm gonna
go with those two you gotta go with
those two well i would say i would agree
with you that's perfect you taking one
side me taking the other side of that
one the person i would kick out and i
know people are mad about it michael
shannon he didn't have any business
being in this honestly him being in it
just made it kind of worse because they
felt they had to aggrandize something
that just didn't have any aggrandization
in it and i'm just like
go win your oscar dude like you need to
go and do other things like i'm i'm sad
for you being in this i don't know who
you got drunk with what poker game you
lost
for me uh and i think it's because i
would rather have had her in it more or
in a sequel uh i really wanted more of
karen uh i forget her last name
yeah
yeah yeah uh i i really wanted more of
her so when she had the one scene or
maybe two scenes i felt like and maybe
it's because she's not a big of a movie
star but i'm so invested in her that i
was like but why are we just they're
more she's incredible like she's good at
stunts she's an incredible actress what
she did in that one scene that was so
much like
there was so much investment in her
standing between brad pittner and taylor
johnson when she didn't come back i was
like was it a cutscene like it just it
it was distracting that i was waiting
for her to come back and she didn't so i
would rather her not be there so i
wasn't like but bring her back i love
her yep exactly exactly um i don't
disagree with you on that one i and hey
look there's
there's obviously some folks that we
know live at the end of this for folks
that haven't seen it i guess we could go
and say there ain't many
yeah now that we're 40 minutes in
spoilers for the bloodbath yeah like
everybody dies no we've said some of the
people that die but yeah there's like
you know there's only like four ish
people walking into the sunset three
fourish people walking into the sunset
so like let's keep it real we don't know
exactly where this can go but we didn't
see her body and this is as much a comic
book movie as anything else so that
means she's alive that's just exactly
that's what i'm saying so i'm like we we
don't know and so i'm going to hold out
that hope for you if nothing else so
that that way we can maybe get um that
kind of well it trained two starring her
and that's barring her
she was the only one on the train she
was like brad pitch she got tagged in
someone else was supposed to work that
day she's a good friend she wasn't
supposed to be there she's not corrupt
she survived this crazy attack and she's
like i just need a vacation i need to
get out of here she's on some remote
area you take it off a train and then
she has to escape that area via another
bullet train and walks right into the
same situation then it's the brad pitt
bad luck but through her bullet train 2
starting karen fucanago wow all right
hey listen i'm not gonna pretend that
that doesn't sound like a great idea i
hope that the folks at sony listen to
you as we all should sir it is always
great to have you come on and chat with
us about films uh where can folks find
you um let us know where your handles
are and where where what you're working
on so all them socials are at koijondro
c-o-y-j-a-n-d-r-e-a-u i just started my
own show over at the real rejects uh
it's called koi's comic corner and
basically i break down i hate
rumors that are seen as fact so i break
down all of my theories about what these
rumors are for comic book properties
based on the comics themselves so when
you hear that doom is going to be in
something i give you 60 to 70 years
worth of comic relevance of how they
might utilize them in each of the films
but i make it very clear these are
theories also when a trailer drops i let
you guys know what comics they're
referencing and how that might lead to
the movies and these things but it's a
really fun basically 20 minute freeform
rant that those poor guys edit down to
12 minutes about me using 70 years of
comic knowledge to hone in on what these
things might actually be and i give
comic recommendations so it's near and
dear to my heart as someone that loves
the actual physical books uh and that's
been what i've been doing a lot lately
you can also find me sometimes
freelancing for nerdist here as much as
i can because i love working with these
folks and generally and genuinely not
sleeping or resting enough but been
making lots and lots of stuff because i
love i love the fact that we get to do
this like these are a conversation we
used to have like outside the movie
theater or in the lobby and now we get
to share our experience on the internet
after you and i run into each other in
the lobby or outside the movie theater i
love it i love it i love it so much um
do you have a recommendation sir i know
that we talked about bullet train but is
there anything you want to recommend for
folks to watch uh i just and i and i
talked about this uh did i talk with you
about wu-tang in american saga uh you
did not but i do know about that because
i did stuff with that show and it is a
great show that more people should be
watching yeah i i've this is the third
time i recommended it but since this is
a new audience i'm gonna keep pushing it
i think it's the show that is the best
thing not getting enough love i would
say it is a breaking bad level crime
thriller meets a walk the line level
biopic and it's about one of the most
important things to music and culture
today it is the foundation of how what i
would argue modern hip-hop was born it's
about being an entrepreneur before it
was a gary v buzzword it's about being
around in a very formative time in
america and it's most importantly about
wu-tang which ain't nothing to mess with
censoring just in case we haven't sworn
yet but it's a movie show that is able
to incorporate eight different through
lines through the eight main members of
wu tang show their varying perspectives
through the real story of what it was
like to be in staten island at that time
and you've got people that are literally
rivals coming together and they're
competing rap battling almost while
being collaborative building this super
group that changed hip hop that changed
american culture while also elaborating
on how messed up
the american experience was slash is for
an entire group of people it's it's not
only terrifyingly topical it's really
important and it'll make you appreciate
not just music but but culture more and
it's so well acted so well written it's
it's honestly it's it's i think
a
emmy-level show that's winning emmys
that didn't get the emmy bump that it
deserves so i'm going to keep singing
its praises like it's it would take an
american song it's on hulu it's maybe my
favorite thing right now
it's incredible i appreciate it i hope
the folks at hulu are listening uh koi
thank you again sir it was always great
talking with you and we will see you all
next time on the after show
you